listen to me we don't want to kill any
of you but trust me we will wake him up
a little what's up guys and girls my
name's Rob joined here with Jake we are
looking at Red Dead Redemption to
official trailer 3 came out today we did
a live stream earlier but now we had
some time to really go back and sift
through this awesome trailer I
personally really liked it yeah we're
gonna go through it and do a little
breakdown because we have some more
thoughts and speculations and I think
some very important details about this
upcoming game ones that are very easy to
miss some ones that you probably noticed
the first time you watched it but we're
gonna hit him anyway yeah totally so
let's just go through the whole thing I
want to say the beginning I think the
most important thing in the beginning is
right when it gives you the date yeah
that's totally fair cuz there was
speculation right like they didn't
really confirm if this was a prequel or
not but no I mean I know it was pretty
clear that it was a prequel and as you
noticed 18 1899 and Red Dead Redemption
1 took place in 1912 yeah a 1911 so this
takes place you know around 1213 years
after and just to kind of set up the
time period McKinley was an office and a
co-worker actually pointed out that
there was a huge blizzard yeah in 1899
which would make sense right because
later in this trailer we see a lot of
snow and in previous trailers we see
them riding through snow and it looks
like you know in general it's gonna take
place a little further to the north than
the previous games total in the previous
game totally and I text is really nice
right like it is you know hammering home
the fact that you're in a gang
you know you're playing we've confirmed
our arthur morgan whether other or not
other characters we don't really know
yet like kind of like a GTA v point of
view but like yeah you know you are in a
gang and you're kind of being dissolved
right like you're as I say tames like
and we'll get into it later but like
federal agents are kind of on
keep putting outlaws on the run right
there hunting them down they're saying
either like the Wild West is dying
yeah like either you're coming to an end
yeah either you're gonna stop or you're
gonna get killed by us so you're
continuing on and theirs doesn't know
Dutch she's returning looks much younger
which makes sense right still fits the
laconic 12 it was 12 years right mm-hmm
and that's like the ultimate takeaway I
feel like is Dutch right like your
relationship with Dutch and his gang
like my speculation is here even with
how they're all talking about yeah we
kind of get a look at the gang here and
we seem a couple times but if you pause
it
yeah that is for sure Bill Williamson
right there to the right of the screen I
think they do a reveal here yeah they do
another one but yeah what I was saying
is that their perspective here like I
personally think that you're gonna start
off with like
Arthur Morgan's gang and later on kind
of merge with you know uh Dutch I could
see something like that considering
they're tying right it's dying and maybe
like you know gangs are like desperate
right and they need to like join up in
order to like stick it out because the
whole thing is about how you know Dutch
is trying to keep everyone together so
that's just this one hypothesis I think
I have we also get that we start to get
that chilling a monologue here about
fire right
we don't really know it I want to say
it's Dutch but I don't think it is I
think it's someone yeah
taming a horse yeah which actually I
mean that's something that was in
previous games you could break horses
yeah prank I'm probably gonna happen in
this you can just tell from that like
that's Arthur Morgan right there for
sure of chasing a herd of horses so city
life and then yet one little thing I
noticed was that bell tower way up there
so in trailer - a bell rings before it
really kicks out the trailer and you see
the top of a tower I'm pretty sure this
is the same town because the bell tower
Oh almost identical yeah well cut to it
and I have something I also want to
bring up later yeah so I'm a but this is
granted from the IMDB but like a
synopsis it's like something has
happened in the beginning right and
there's all this talk about a fire I
think that and what you just said even
further makes me believe it is at this
town maybe they robbed a bank the town
goes up in flames yeah I can they kill a
lot of innocent people that's why at the
trailer one he was like you got to run
and don't look back
time comes you gotta run and don't look
back this next shot is super interesting
- yeah because like like so Rockstar
always typically has like diversions you
can do you can in GTA 5 you go see a
movie as Michael and even Red Dead
Redemption you'd go to the movie right
this looks like a show and I'm almost
certain you'll be able to walk in here
and watch this but another thing that's
worth pointing out too is that this
doesn't look like a small town show this
looks like the right man for Minh see
the furnishing and like you know lining
of all of like just architecture right
look this doesn't look like you know
compared to this town it doesn't look
like you something from there yeah so
like maybe this is inferring like big
city life you know yeah and you we
actually get another glimpse when
they're when they're robbing that Bank
yeah and deploying a backdrop of a yeah
so I think you're right and even
regarding this town going up in flames
like there's a tower there Church tower
also they're pretty elevated you know
what I mean and then you look back to
the shot of this town like this is a
phat cliff they could be looking down
from that angle you know a mean or just
a different side of it but regardless
this isn't a flat plain you know just to
point out someone then read it comments
were saying Oh Saints Hotel like
Louisiana confirmed and it's like I
don't think there are any cliffs this
high in Louisiana yeah I mean as I
mentioned before like Red Dead
Redemption one had black water which is
kind of like a Louisiana bayou style
area and I think we'll see something
like that toilet but as far as taking
place in Louisiana yeah
that's a good shot oh yeah there's tons
of those right here yeah you're right
back it up a little bit right there so
that look at you see a god we even yeah
you're absolutely right that's a train
passing by looks like power lines it and
this looks like Blackwater - I would say
oh yeah like yeah I mean that looks like
part of Blackwater and then there we get
to see Bill Williamson again you tell
cuz that folded had up like that's what
always what he was wearing and Red Dead
Redemption one has to be him here I want
to hear his voice again though I'm
looking forward to hear cuz his voice is
so good yeah little chest hair - well
Chester yeah I love I love this this
line of this character I get a Trevor
vibe in the sense of just like how you
know if you look at like the size of the
spectrum right like I feel like you're
gonna start seeing with the with the
greater outlaw group you're gonna have
people who are bad really really bad and
good you know what I mean like I swear
as morals and stuff like that he just
looked like the body language yeah of
Morgan here like and he's saying like
you know hey people make mistakes
maybe this fire that happened exactly I
think you're totally right like it's
like regretting the fact that this this
robbery job went wrong they killed some
people and he's like hey listen like
this is gonna happen we just have to
fall out dutch or whoever yeah basically
you stop being such a wuss yeah keep
your head up and like get the job done
because he can totally like just
breeding right this body language we
just you don't see his eyes he's looking
down it's right pretty damn good it is
and it goes also show how awesome
they're like direction and scimitar fee
is yeah
so that looks gameplay ish I have it
totally on her yeah so in the in the
previous trailer mm-hmm we saw a woman
morning and it looked like a mother I
this is a theory I'm sure people are
gonna be like no that's not right but my
theory is that maybe this is John
Martins ball
yeah I I don't really have a lot of
evidence to back that up but I don't
know according to the lower John
Marsten's mother was an unnamed
prostitute who died when he was young he
looks kind of older when we see him in a
bit but I don't know they could always
rewrite it change it I wouldn't be
surprised if we see his mom there could
oh yeah I mean in the other trailer -
you had him talking to a boy whether
that whether or not that's Marston I
mean I don't know if that's even pushing
it you know he's just like he's talking
to the kid and he's saying like oh I'll
basically kill you just like I killed
your mom maybe yeah I'll help you and
blah or I'll keep your mom in black oh
that's what it was excuse me be adding
them there could be a time drum and here
we go yeah this is a big one that we
didn't notice until later but yeah you
go ahead I mean there's that guy who
looks like the antagonist he looks that
you were saying like pointing out the
bowler hats like these guys are probably
Marshalls right
yeah the bowler hats the ties the
outfits yeah you can barely see it here
and later on we'll get through later but
like they all kind of seem to be wearing
the same stuff and that being like red
vests I feel like yeah similar tire with
the bowler hats even matching hats you
could say but one other thing that yeah
that we missed initially a couple times
was this guy over here I mean we all
kind of a theory that this could be
Edgar Ross who was the main antagonist
of Red Dead Redemption like totally he
was the one who kind of pushed you along
to eliminate the rest of your rest of
the gang totally and he shows up at the
end he shows up periodically throughout
the story but if you compare them
side-by-side they look pretty similar of
course in Red Dead Redemption he looks
older his mustache is graying but I I
don't see why that wouldn't be him I
think that makes total sense I agree and
it also makes sense that you know that
this you know there's a hierarchy here
right by by positioning like he's behind
whoever this federal agent or Marshall
is and you're led to believe that he is
a main intactness right like he is
is the anti outlaw clearly and you could
probably infer that he's gonna die
and then who's in charge next right for
the setup to the next game yeah I think
that's totally it and then here's a nice
shot of everyone yeah well I mean at
least what we think is everyone that guy
right up there to the left
that guy also appeared in previous
trailers too right get his hair back
though you guys hair back yeah and at
first I was like I don't know if that's
him but they're wearing pretty much the
same shirts and it was this like white
spotted blue shirt and this is this is a
big group right and it's a clearly a
dividing line here right yeah and of
course you've got Arthur Morgan right
behind Dutch right and like I love this
game is gonna be like I feel like
rounding up more outlaws who are on the
run
you know maybe individuals or like
smaller groups like trying to like it
stylish a bigger outlaw group that's
like what this is really signifying you
know yeah
and then here this to me that's that's a
nice beer it's a big bushy beard it's
like the guy from Game of Thrones I know
this to me looks like game play like I
know we don't see a lot and I know we
don't see this looks like kind of like
you know how GTA 5 had that director
mode where you could kind of like use
the camera it looks like someone yeah
yeah totally similar yeah and they're
framing gameplay moments I mean yeah -
right here right after right we see a
Fight Club going on which once again
like makes me kind of think that I bet
there's gonna be fight clubs as a
diversion - I could see that happening
yeah yeah this isn't just like a fight
right like these guys have their shirts
off yeah Legler cheer people are
cheering it's it's definitely like an
activity for sure I would definitely see
that yeah that takedown is like very
reminiscent of like just like a gameplay
takedown yeah exactly
yeah and then this has to be the
antagonist so a lot more of this fire
right maybe this is what they
accidentally do so here's what I was
inferring later is that I mean maybe
this is like a different town and like
each town has like different hats but
like I now feel like because these
basically these could be you know
federal agents or like gunfire they got
red yeah Red Hat sorry red vests and
like matching hats I don't know if I'm
getting Isaac does each town have like
their own respective hats that they wear
there it is this is this is the shot
this is what this trailer was all about
this is what totally has me even more
hyped like clearly clear clearly John
Marston like I know some people are
confused they're like well how is how
could this be John Marston after what
happened in one and it's like well first
of all this is a prequel yeah so there's
that and second of all like those scars
are fresh look how much younger he looks
right this is a hundred percent John
Marston totally time percent yeah I
don't think there's anything to debate
hurt that's that's what it is yeah it's
funny to think like and if it wasn't why
would they make him so similar I know or
play scars they're like correct yeah so
what what I think is interesting though
is I'm curious who they're gonna have
voice him which is kind of a tangent but
that voice actor was
much done after red that he has done
anything since so I'm curious if they
got him back I hope they did because
he's so good so yeah there's the more
the blizzard stuff right yeah looks a
bit cold there we go looks like you
Dutch just weathered the blizzard yeah
then again this is like this looks very
remorseful you know yeah Bret like
something had happened burned the whole
freaking town down he's at fault well
that's about it yeah that's it and then
of course we get the release date
October 26th yeah 2018 it's been a long
wait but we are closing in and I am so
excited this trailer got me very excited
as well I really like this like conflict
that seems to be brewing yeah it's way
more like pronounced here you have a lot
of sides it seems yeah I'm very excited
man yeah and I think above all like just
seeing John Marston again was so cool
like by far one of the best characters
in a video game to see him come back
which is like something Rockstar
typically doesn't do right like normally
it's like every GTA game is very
different like they'll reference each
other but that's sure so seeing him man
I feel so good yeah it's great
well cool that just about does it thank
you guys for watching if you have any
rumors or speculations or you know
Easter eggs anything I guess do leave
them in the comments I'm curious to see
if there's anything else we missed
well thanks check thank you
[Music]